TOGETHER ALTHOUGH YOU DON’T
HEAR THEM AT THE WHITE HOUSE
BRIEFING ANYMORE.
LELAND:  WITH REGARD  RECORD
CASES IN SOME STATES.
A LOOK AT HOW IT’S IMPACTING
THE ECONOMY.
MR. SCALIA, APPRECIATE YOU
TAKING THE TIME ON A SATURDAY.
I REMEMBER TAKING THIS CHAIR IN
SATURDAY BACK IN MARCH AND WE
WERE TALKING ABOUT 15 DAYS OF
SHUTTING DOWN BUSINESSES, TO
QUOTE, SLOW THE SPREAD.
WE’RE NOW IN LATE JUNE, ALMOST
JULY AND PARTS OF TEXAS ARE
SHUTTING DOWN ONCE AGAIN.
IS IT TIME TO ADMIT THAT THE
ECONOMIC EFFECTS OF THIS AND
THUS, THE ECONOMIC SUBSIDIES TO
HELP WITH THOSE ARE GOING TO
HAVE TO GO ON FOR A LOT LONGER
THAN WE ORIGINALLY THOUGHT?
>> WELL, I THINK WE DID SLOW
THE SPREAD AND WE DID FLATTEN
THE CURVE OF, WHICH WAS THE
OBJECTIVES THAT WERE TAKEN
MARCH, APRIL AND FOR LOT OF THE
COUNTRY IN MAY, TOO, AND WE
MADE TREMENDOUS PROGRESS BOTH
IN CONTAINING THE VIRUS AND
ALSO IN BUILDING UP OUR MEDICAL
CAPACITY SO THAT THERE ARE
FLAREUPS, LELAND, WE’RE READY
TO CONTEND WITH THEM.
WE ALWAYS KNEW THE VIRUS WOULD
STILL BE AROUND.
WE ARE REMINDED BY WHAT’S GOING
ON IN SOME CITIES, THERE ARE
STILL CIRCUMSTANCES THAT CALL
FOR CARE, CAUTION, BECAUSE THE
VIRUS IS STILL HERE, BUT WE’RE
REOPENING SAFELY AND
SUCCESSFULLY THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTRY, PUTTING MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE BACK TO WORK.
LELAND:  MILLIONS OF PEOPLE ARE
GOING BACK TO WORK.
THERE’S ALSO MILLIONS OF PEOPLE
OR HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS PEOPLE
NOW WHO HAVE GONE BACK TO WORK
WHO ARE NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO
GO BACK TO WORK ANYMORE.
THEY’RE GOING TO BE EMPLOYED BY
BUSINESSES THAT ARE GOING TO
HAVE TO SHUT DOWN AGAIN.
IN TEXAS, IN FLORIDA, THERE’S
TALK MUCH NEW SHUTDOWNS IN
ARIZONA, STAY-AT-HOME
SUGGESTIONS IF NOT ORDERS
PERHAPS COMING IN LOS ANGELES.
SO IS THERE GOING TO NEED TO BE
ANOTHER ROUND OF PPP OR THE
$600 UNEMPLOYMENT TOP-UP
INSURANCE?
IS THAT GOING TO HAVE TO HAPPEN
NOW?
>> WELL, I THINK THERE’S A NEED
ABOVE ALL, LELAND, FOR PEOPLE
TO CONTINUE TO EXERCISE
SELF-DISCIPLINE AND CAUTION,
SOCIAL DISTANCING, MASKS IN
MANY CIRCUMSTANCES.
IN TERMS OF WHAT MIGHT BE DONE
WITH FURTHER LEGISLATION, SOME
OF THE PROGRAMS THAT YOU’VE
MENTIONED ARE GOING TO EXPIRE
AT THE END OF THE JULY.
I THINK THERE WILL BE
DISCUSSIONS AS THAT APPROACHES
ABOUT WHETHER ADDITIONAL
MEASURES ARE NEEDED.
THE UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFIT YOU
MENTIONED WAS AN IMPORTANT
THING TO BE DOING AS WE CLOSED
OUR ECONOMY.
THAT $600 A WEEK ADDITIONAL
FEDERAL BENEFIT.
BUT I THINK AS WE REOPEN THE
ECONOMY, WE’RE NOT GOING TO
WANT TO CONTINUE THAT
PARTICULAR BENEFIT, BUT I THINK
THERE’S A GOOD DISCUSSION TO BE
HAD WHETHER THERE ARE MEASURES
WE STILL WILL NEED.
LELAND:  YOU WERE DOWN IN TEXAS
EARLIER THIS WEEK TALKING TO
BUSINESS LEADERS IN DALLAS.
HERE IS WHAT NOTED DALLAS
BUSINESSMAN MARKU CUBAN HAS TO
SAY.
>> WHEN THERE’S A PROBLEM YOU
STEP UP AND YOU PROVIDE
COMFORT, AND YOU PROVIDE
DETAILS, SO WE CAN MAKE
DECISIONS ABOUT OUR HEALTH AND
ABOUT THE ECONOMY.
HE HASN’T DONE THAT.
LELAND:  HE HE’S REFERRING TO
IS THE PRESIDENT.
AND I DIDN’T IMAGINE THAT THE
SHUT DOWN IS A VIABLE OPTION AS
THE GOVERNOR IS ORDERING.
>> THERE, AGAIN, IS NEED TO BE
CAREFUL ABOUT THE VIRUS, BUT
THERE’S LOT OF GOOD STUFF GOING
ON IN OUR ECONOMY AND THAT’S
WHAT A LOT OF MY DISCUSSION
WITH THE BUSINESS LEADERS WAS
ABOUT.
WE HAD A JOBS REPORT IN MAY
THAT WAS STUPENDOUS.
WE’RE SEEING RECORD LEVEL
INCREASES, SAME THING WITH NEW
HOME CONSTRUCTION.
THERE’S A LOT OF REALLY
POSITIVE SIGNS AND I HEARD A
LOT OF OPTIMISM ABOUT REOPENING
AND REOPENING SAFELY AND THAT
WAS A CONVERSATION IN TEXAS
EARLIER THIS WEEK.
SO, I THINK, AGAIN, THIS WEEK
WAS ALSO GOOD FOR AMERICAN
WORKERS.
THE PRESIDENT SIGNED A COUPLE
OF ORDERS, MONDAY SIGNED THAT
ORDER TO SUSPEND FURTHER
IMMIGRANT WORKERS SO WE CAN GET
AMERICANS ALL BACK TO WORK AND
THEN FRIDAY SIGNED A REALLY
IMPORTANT ORDER ABOUT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT NOT
REQUIRING COLLEGE DEGREES FOR
JOBS WHERE THEY’RE NOT NEEDED.
LELAND:  INTERESTING.
>> TWO-THIRDS OF AMERICANS
DON’T HAVE A COLLEGE DEGREE SO
THIS OPENS THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO MORE WORKERS.
I THINK THERE ARE A LOT OF OF
REALLY GOOD THINGS GOING ON,
GOOD FOR AMERICAN WORKERS, BUT
THE VIRUS IS STILL SOMETHING WE
KEEP AN EYE ON.
LELAND:  INTERESTING WHAT YOU
SAID ABOUT THE COLLEGE DEGREES.
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE YOU BACK
AND WHAT THAT MIGHT MEAN AND
THOSE JOBS THAT OUGHT TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE.
MR. SECRETARY, APPRECIATE YOU